let's rock so you guys want to hear
something absolutely insane well in the
last 40 months my YouTube grew from zero
to 2.23 million subscribers my Instagram
Grew From 7,000 to 2 and a half million
sub subscribers followers you get the
idea my LinkedIn went from Zer to
324,000 followers My Tik Tok went from
zero to $856,000 followers my Twitter
SLX the artist formerly known as Twitter
uh went from0 to 600
17,000 my Facebook which we just started
went from 0 to 25,00 there we go going
in big Facebook um my podcast went from
3,000 downloads to 25 million downloads
and my email subscribers went from 0 to
700,000 for a grand total of two billion
Impressions over that time period and
7.8 million new
subscribers and for a grand total of a
million copies sold of my book for those
of you who are like well what does that
mean and I'll get to that in a second so
in 40ish months all of that happened and
I show all of this is proof to start
this to show one thing is that
this actually
works and you can build a brand without
babes without stunts or
kittens and I start this proof because
lots of people talk about stuff that
they haven't done and teach a lot of
sucky fluff as a result you can see the
man there he's saying the truth this
this fluff
sucks and I refus to do
that and so before we got the two
billion Impressions and the 7.8 million
subscribers it wasn't like
this because 40 months ago I started
with zero subscribers and a big quote
fancy
plan and my fancy plan had Three Steps
step one make as much good stuff as I
could step two post it everywhere I
could and step three learn as much as I
could and after 40ish
months $4 million in team equipment
vendors Studios and
software a thousand hours of me on
camera recording and 35,000 pieces of
content let me say that again
35,000 as in count to a th000 and then
do that 35 times in a
row I learned a lot of What Not to
do but I did learn six things that made
money and grew my brand that you can use
today now what I'd like to do is for the
remainder of the presentation save you
the three and a half years and $4
million so you can just get the lessons
without the scar so that little box is
our box of six lessons
cool all right let's rock so here are
the six changes that we observed over
the last four 40ish months that actually
worked number one going from edutainment
to
education number two for us to for you
number three wide to narrow number four
views to revenue number five shorts to
Longs number six assume more to assume
nothing now most of those I promise you
I will explain and if it looks like uh I
think I know what that means believe me
there's a lot more underneath of it so
let's start with the first one
edutainment to
education so I see content in three
buckets on one extreme you've got
entertainment which is the entire point
of entertainment just to define the term
is to get people to watch the only point
of the entertainment is to just get
people to consume it that's it if it
accomplishes that it has
succeeded on the other side you have
education where the point of education
is to get someone to change what they do
right right if you try and teach someone
how to answer a phone and then in the
same situation the phone rings and they
don't do something and then after they
watch you do something they then change
what they do in the phone rings the
second time they have learned so the
point is to change their behavior if
educ if the video or the content does
that then you succeeded at educating
them and lastly you have edutainment
which has the point of both trying to
teach and entertaining at the same time
and to be clear it's less that you make
entertaining content or that you make
educational content it's more that you
make content and people are either
entertained or educated as a result and
so you can make one thing that
entertains some people and then that
same thing educates other people and so
I just want to make this very clear that
you don't control the audience you make
something and then education or
entertainment
occurs but for our purposes I'll Define
the content category is the most common
outcome of your content and so if a lot
of people are entertained then you've
made entertaining content for the
purpose of this presentation even if one
or two people learn something so for
example some creators might learn stuff
from Mr BEAST's videos wow I learned how
to make videos but the vast majority of
people are entertained they watch just a
watch on the other hand Walla who's one
of the number one Educators on YouTube
you can even see the different looking
feels and don't worry I'm going to get
into that he may entertain some
enthusiasts around that subject
but mostly he educates
students and until recently I've been
trying to figure this out I've spent a
lot of time really working through this
and so I actually have videos in all
three buckets I have entertainment
videos where the point is to get people
to watch I have edutainment videos where
we try and teach and entertain at the
same time and then we have education
videos where we just want to change
people's behavior we just want to teach
them something and so the first change
number one that we see over lots of the
data I'll support in a second is that
I'm going all in on
education for three reasons number one
is that when we looked at all of our
data All Views are not created equal
I'll dive into that in a second number
two is I like educational videos and
number three is I like people who like
educational videos too Andor people who
educate themselves people who want to
learn and so let me explain these so all
views are not created equal so there's
this Theory and this is going to this
will be one that's going to Rattle some
cages there's a theory that media works
like a funnel in fact the vast majority
of marketing infographics and things
like that almost all are
funnels and the theory goes like this
you make entertaining
content and then the theory states that
people who watch that content then we'll
go to more educational content okay
sounds simple enough we've got something
wide we got something narrow fantastic
but in our experience in my experience
and based on our book sales based on our
email optins and based on the
applications we receive at acquisition.
comom to become portfolio companies it
works much more like this which is that
entertainment people want more
entertainment content and education
people want more say it with me
education
content and so in other words these
people do not become these people not in
any appreciable rate that we would build
a business around and they certainly
don't read the books Jo join the email
list or apply to become portfolio
businesses so if I want more of these
people then they deserve the stuff that
they
value and so that's the first reason
that I'm doubling down on education All
Views are not created equal number two
the next is that I simply like doing it
all right so you know I do believe that
you should try and do stuff that you
like doing and if it happens to also be
in align with your goals awesome it's
much tougher when the thing you like
doing isn't align with your goals but in
this instance when I got that first
piece of data I was like thank God
because this is the stuff I like making
most all right and so when I talk to
Ideal customers in my mind they are
business owners and business interested
people because if you know me and
anybody who who's close to me would
probably attested this is that like if
you hang out with me for any amount of
time we will probably talk about
business because it's what I love
talking about I I eat it I sleep it I
drink it I work seven days on it and
like I skip holidays for it because for
me it is the holiday so this is what I
like doing and this is what the people
that I like serving also
like and so they like it better
too and this is where got confusing for
me leading up to this and why this is so
important is that it got very confusing
when you have so many people saying man
I really like the entertaining content
and this is where it gets difficult this
is where you have to read between the
lines of the comments rather than just
reading the comments themselves all
right because the thing is is for us or
at least for me they weren't necessarily
who I was trying to attract again
there's nothing wrong with that I mean
hey if I could serve the whole world I
will but I know that I tend to do better
serving people who want to educate
themselves than people who just want to
watch or consume just for the sake of it
and so that's why I'm debling down on
going from edutainment some enter
edutainment some entertainment to
education so that's number one so let's
talk about change number two that we
saw going from for us to for you you're
like what does that mean let me explain
so recently a mutual friend came to the
headquarters and he said hey I've been
consuming your stuff for years but
recently I just haven't been watching as
much and he said it offhandedly wasn't
like trying to smash my ego into bits um
and he failed at that
uh but when he said it I really took it
to heart right it was very gut-wrenching
he said it just doesn't resonate as much
I was like okay got it it felt like a
gut punch since he's literally the
person I could help most this is a
business owner doing 10 million plus a
year and I was like man well that sucks
and that's when I realized that reading
the comments actually led me a little
bit astray and for you it might be
leading you astray and I'll give you
some data to support that and so some
people loved our different styles but
not the people that I ultimately wanted
to help or am best suited to serve and
so we realized that we were serving the
wrong who and that had some very
significant Downstream impacts on what
we made and how we made it so what is
making for them or for business owners
content really mean let me break this
down into tactics all right so
tactically it meant five
things number one different packaging
number two different
introductions number three different
meat number four different visuals and
number five different what I'll call
pre-work all right so let's start with
number one so the difference between
these two thumbnails is going from vague
to clear all right so if I looked at all
the stuff that we did in the past if I
said what is the video on the left about
you'd probably be like I a rule of some
sort that might have to do with money
not sure if I said what's the what's the
video on the right the yellow background
video if I were to describe it I'd
probably say a map or a blueprint or
schematics of some sort that go from
zero to a million okay well guess
what the one on the right it's exactly
that the one on the left actually has
nothing to do with what that thumbnail
looks like and what do you know when
people click on something that they
don't know what it's about they have a
smaller percentage of getting something
they actually want than if you say this
is what this is about and then they get
exactly what they think it's
about so we're going from vague to clear
in both what it looks like the
thumbnails and what we say about it the
headlines so that's number one from a
packaging perspective that we will be
changing Andor going more all in on and
I want to take a pause here for a second
about this there was also kind of a
pervasive narrative in in the kind of
marketing world is like you got to have
curiosity you got to like you don't want
to tell them everything you want them to
to be able to get no like if they want
that thing they will click on that thing
and then you just give them that thing
and that has been a very hard lesson for
me to learn and so I share it with you
now so the second is different
introductions you guys feeling this okay
good okay different introductions now
this one is really big so going from
confirming the thumbnail or confirming
the headline to proof and this is super
important I'll explain the difference so
a lot of the things that I learned like
many of you if you are trying to get
into content creation of any sort or
media is that you look at the people who
are who are the biggest right and so
often times the biggest people in media
are entertainers now why is that because
everyone gets value from entertainment
but there is no one thing from an
education perspective that can provide
value to everyone why because everyone
already knows different stuff so if I
educate a wide slice of people there's
still already people who know that thing
and then do not get value so
entertainment by definition will always
be greater or larger the followings for
those people than people who educate
there is no no bones about it like it is
that way and so a lot of the lessons
that entertainment teaches everyone
listens to because they have the biggest
followings but I don't think the actual
tactics they subscribe or espouse are
correct at a tactical level at a
principal level yes and so so let me
just say a second about what that
principle is is that the person who's
going to consume the content we want to
increase their perceived likelihood that
they will get what they clicked so just
like the headline and just like the
thumbnails now when they said in
entertainment you want to confirm it
well that's because most of the
Sensational entertainment is something
crazy and so the likelihood that someone
just got the click so that they could
not do that crazy thing is pretty high
and so if you want people to watch you
smash a Lamborghini then you better have
the Lamborghini next to you or people
aren't going to believe that you're
actually going to smash
it now let's flip to entertainment for a
second sorry let's SL let's switch to
education for a second if I say I'm
going to teach you a physics thing I'm
going to teach you about the law of I
don't even know what the first law of
physics is but if you push it it will
move something like that
anyways if I want to have proof or
increase the perceived likelihood that
they're going to be well taught then
what I actually have to do is edify the
person why should I listen to you if I'm
the viewer there's a zillion people that
could write something on a board but if
you're a PhD physicist then the
likelihood that I will listen to you and
that I will get what I want is much
higher and so in both of these examples
we are actually doing the same thing but
we do it differently if you want to
educate and for me when I looked at my
videos and I'll explain the data in a
second it became really
clear and so in entertainment it's say
the title again and then literally show
them what was on the thumbnail in
education it's show them that you can do
what you promised them in the thumbnail
and that's the
difference and to figure out what made
intros for our videos work I actually
rewatched my top 35 educational videos
this actually took some time and so let
me just save you like a lot of hours and
just give you the Nugget and so I
actually developed a new moniker around
how to think about introd for ourselves
that I'm spreading throughout my whole
team and you can just steal
it proof promise plan so I'll break down
all three of these so all of the
introductions of the best education
videos that we had had these three
characteristics and I want to make one
point about the order of these is that
you can have these three mixed in any
order you want I would emphasize the one
that is the most important for that
particular piece of content so if you
have something that you're making
that you think the proof is going to be
really important then lead with that if
you have a promise that's incredibly
important for the audience then lead
with that if you have a plan that for
some reason is going to be more
emphasized than lean with that but I
would say that for our content for the
most because I'm a business educator
about making money in
general most people have this big
glaring sign above their head before
they can even turn on the volume of
their brain which is why should I listen
to you and so I tend to lead with
proof and so proof is that you prove
that you know what you're you're talking
about you give people a reason to
believe you the promise is to tell them
what they're going to get or learn from
the video and the plan sets the
expectations of what will happen next so
let me give you a real world example of
this I started this presentation with
data that shows that I've done what I'm
talking about if I went up here and just
skipped this part you might be like okay
all of this up to this point why should
I listen to you and you'd be right in
thinking that because you have no idea
who I am I could just be some random
dude that looks like a birken stock
slightly Lumberjack eish weirdly Dressed
Man like why would you listen and you'd
be reasonable to believe that right but
if you start with that then you're like
okay well he know
something the promise was what I said
you would get at the beginning I said I
learned six things that made money and
grew my brain that you can use today and
I'm going to save you $4 million in
three and a half years and you'll just
get all the lessons that I learned that
was the promise making sense okay and
then finally we had the plan I said how
are we going to get there how am I to
complete that promise I said well
there's six changes and I'm going to
walk through them that's the plan and so
leading with those things we found got
business owners or the people that I'm
interested in to actually better frame
and perceive and get educated on the
content that we're talking
about and so that's what we're changing
out of our
introductions third now let's talk about
how this strategy changes the meat of
the content what we're actually like the
the real bones the potatoes all right is
that going from be real SL Vlog stuff
because we have made that to list steps
and stories when we looked at the
educational content that did the best
they had more of the right and less of
the
left from Razzle I would I would love to
say to Dazzle but it really is it's just
Razzle on the left and so I actually
wanted to show a different type of
content so I don't want to make this
seem like this is all YouTube I just
have like long form video there has all
of the elements and some platforms don't
have all of them so you YouTube's a very
easy platform to base this off of but
this is from Instagram and Tik Tok would
function the same way Etc so if you look
at the squares here I just pulled the
last 30 days of content that we made and
I looked at our bottom performing over
the last 30 days that we posted that
were reals and then I looked at the top
now
interestingly it was a almost a perfect
reversal so the
bottom 12 videos that we made eight out
of 12 I would say had more Razzle
emphasized it was more about effects a
little bit higher production and on the
flip side and this is what was crazy and
this is why I'm sharing stuff with you
because like I would I would literally
never have guessed it and that's why we
look N9 out of 12 75% of the best videos
we had emphasize language emphasize the
actual message more than the production
and so it was about emphasizing the
language rather than the Razzle I find
this very fascinating now to be really
clear you can have really bad language
you're like poor vague unclear language
and it won't do well and you might have
Razzle that just absolutely crushes I
just look at the trends of of 75% on
this side were this style or this type
and 75% that weren't as good were this
style well then let's do more of this
and less of
that and so those are the main meat
Changers that we're doing in the videos
we're emphasizing language this also was
true with Longs as well so if I go and
show you this real quick language that's
on the screen and that's one of our best
videos ever and that takes up 70 80% of
the video is actually just words
interesting for me at least I mean I was
a little offended cuz thought I had a
you know good face but apparently no one
cares so that's what we're changing
about the meat so let's talk about
visuals this one's a big one all right
so going from over production and I want
to be clear not over production over
production for the objective so it's not
like we did like my team did anything
wrong or anything like that it's just
that if we want to educate sometimes
production distracts from the objective
of Education if the point for
entertainment is to get someone to watch
then adding lots of things can be a good
thing but if you're trying to learn
physics and there's whizbangs and popups
and changing backgrounds it's really
hard to learn and if that's the
throughput or that's the point of the
video that it actually detracts rather
than ads and so the difference that I
put in this example here is we have a
background that changes colors while I'm
teaching something it does not help
someone understand the subject matter
better fundamentally changing background
color will not help anyone learn more on
the flip side clar ver ifying what words
on a screen are because maybe my
handwriting is not that good would help
people understand that's the difference
so over production to effective
production from distracting to
enhancing from visual effects to
visualizing data so instead of having
Flames behind me it's what does this
look like on a chart so we can give
relative scale so we have scope so we
can show changes over
time and so that's how the visuals
that did the best looked
like and then number five let's talk
about pre-work for a second so going
from postproduction to pre-search so
instead of saying hey let's just record
something and then fix it in post
anybody who's in the media side knows
what I'm talking about four weeks of
editing after you know almost no prep to
get a video out well what if we did four
weeks of research and then we have
almost no editing because we thought of
everything ahead of time well guess what
the videos where we spent I mean we're
like the the the hour to hour ratio is
stupid and I'll get to that in a second
but if we spend a quarter of the time
that we used to spend on Post in Pre we
eliminate
90% 90 maybe 95% of our post edit work
and man-hours and for the business
owners in the room that's real cost
that's real savings and for the also
business owners in the room that also
means increased production so if I can
take the quarter of the time and I can
get almost zero time on the back end
that's four times the videos but not
only is it four times the output it's
also higher quality for your goal and
your audience so this is a big thing
that we noticed the videos that we spoke
the most time on the front end we spent
less time on the back and they did
better and so we want to spend more time
before than after and so this is my
little quote if you want to write
something down uh an ounce of pre-work
is worth a pound of post so that was my
little my little take on this and so by
focusing more on what educates and what
it means we do great and everything else
distract from that
goal and so those are the five things
that we're changing tactically and that
we're doubling down on to cater to
business owners this at least for my
audience is what they cared
about and I happen to be in that
audience and I feel that way too so I'm
happy about it so that's how we went
from for us as media people to a degree
because I've got into this now uh to for
you or for your audience and for me that
means for business
owners so now let's talk about why daero
all right and this will also ruffle some
feathers and rattle some cages so
instead of talking about relationships
and college and food and
lifestyle I'm going to be narrowing down
or doubling down on if you will business
business
models business
leverage and selling in a business
notice business being in all of these
videos and all these topics and so
that's how I'm going narrower very
simple now that I'm going to go back a
slide because I want I want to head on
this for a
second just like I said earlier that
people who like Entertainment also just
want more entertainment what we also
found is that people who I'll go back
quick people who watch relationship
stuff want more relationship stuff and
as they should that's what they clicked
on that's what they want that makes
sense and people who want to learn about
college are people trying to make a
decision about college guess what those
people probably aren't business
owners and people who want to learn
about food they watch other food videos
and people want about lifestyle probably
watch other lifestyle videos but for me
those were not necessarily the people
that vibed the most with my stuff and
that makes sense because to be fair this
is a little bit more foreign to me when
I talk about business I feel very
comfortable when I talk about these
things I just give what I would consider
hot takes this is my
perspective so that is what we're
doubling down on in terms of the topics
that were choosing for the content we
make so that's number three let's go
number four in terms of the the things
we're doubling down on so before this we
used to track views this is another big
one man all six of these are big man I'm
glad I made a presentation about so
before this we used to track views as
our primary metric so I'll take a second
here who uses be honest be honest
everybody's like likes don't you can't
trade likes for for paying rent you
can't pay pay roll with view sure okay
got it who here actually tracks
something besides
views me say it again who makes views
the most important metric you
track all right right a lot of you
that's okay me too but I'm going to give
you a good metric that you can track and
this is after pouring through believe me
I'm I'm a big data guy um a metric that
you might not
expect so the main reason is that I had
a 6 to 12 month deal cycle so I started
by using views because I really had no
other metric because for those you who
don't know what I do well I'll explain
in a second but we had no idea what what
it would do besides driving awareness
and I didn't really have any other
objective right but in that time period
of doing a deal in every six to 12
months because we buy companies that's
more or less what we do um we begin
seeing a much closer correlation with
faster feedback metrics and ideally in
any business you want as little latency
between the metrics you track and the
behavior you want to change and so if
you want to get people to change
something and you want to look at
something that takes a year to get
feedback really tough to change Behavior
but if you can have a a metric that you
can see daily changes or hourly changes
then those are things that are going to
much more quickly change Behavior so
that you can have a 100 feedback loops
in terms of changing and getting better
than one every
year and so besides Book Sales optins
and applications there was a metric that
stood out as fastest and most measurable
it was ad revenue and this is really
surprising to me so and I this is the
point I want to make real quick is that
to be clear for those you who don't know
who I am ad revenue is not how I make my
money all right just very clearly um for
those you don't know my wife and I exit
our first big company uh for $ 46.2
million in December of 2021 you can
Google it American Pacific group was the
private Equity Firm gym launch and
Prestige labs are two of those companies
um and since then we invested and bought
a number of companies that have grown a
lot and do over $200 million a year so I
do media to feed a lot of different
things but I don't directly monetize the
media and like ad revenue is I'll
explain why in a second is an important
metric that we can use for everything
else okay so these are companies that we
own great so for me I pretty much always
ignored ad revenue and just saw it as
something that could offset some of the
cost of the immedia team there was
really nothing else but I was wrong it's
actually so much more so let's let's
dive into a little bit for a second like
how does AD Revenue come to be so it
comes from two things this number of
views times Revenue per views now the
actual term is RPMs which is revenue per
meal which is French for thousand
but it's number of views times the
revenue that you get okay per view
fantastic so it takes into account and
this is why this is important because we
thought views and that was the only
metric we had but we had to have
something to counter it because
otherwise then you get views for view
sake but we needed a quality metric with
a quantity metric which by the way
paired metrics if you're ever tracking
something for a department having like
number of tickets resolved with rating
against the the the resolution of how
well those customer service reps
resolved paired metrics allow you to get
to to the best or most effective
throughput for any department and I just
didn't know enough about media to find
out what our paired metric was and this
happens to be a single metric that pairs
both and so it takes account the quality
of the audience which for me was
business owners who have amongst the
highest spending power and so RPMs are
the highest now for so for me the RPMs
go up it means I'm getting more of the
quality people that I want and so this
gave me and my team something that we
could shoot for that bounc making videos
for the right people who wanted to watch
so I mean ideally we absolutely want to
crank views with the right people and
that's what that was able to track for
us and looking backwards the month with
the highest RPMs and AD Revenue also
created the most Book Sales the most
optins and the most business
applications and this had nothing to do
with how many views we got in fact we
did kind of an experiment lately where
we did 90 days of almost no business
stuff we just did more uh more
edutainment and entertainment style uh
content and our views went through the
roof like Way up 2 3x what we're
accustomed to but even with the increase
in views our ad Revenue dropped by
half so we're actually getting the wrong
people and I share this with you so you
don't have
to and so the nice thing about this from
a team perspective for those who do have
larger teams and want to translate this
over is that my team now has real-time
access to this so they can see every
single piece of content in the ad
Revenue that it generates and they can
quickly generate baselines in their mind
of what's good and what's bad on an
objective metric that really is good and
bad rather than just like hey this video
cranked yeah but it didn't it didn't
bring any of the right people we got
this thing that had 10 million views
okay but it drove nothing versus we had
this video that had what 100,000 views
and it made more ad Revenue than one
that had 10 million and we saw the
corresponding increase in the metrics
that matter to
us and so that's why we switch from
views being the metric that we're
optimizing for to add Revenue because
it's a leading performance indicator it
happens almost in real time rather than
something that happens in a big in a
rears to give a fancy word later so
that's number four in terms of the
things that we're doubling down
on so let's talk about the fifth one
shorts to Longs all right this is yet
and end another big one that's going to
ruffle some feathers so for a long time
the prevailing idea in content marketing
was again a funnel it's like
everything's a funnel all right and it
was believed that shorts viewers got
more people to
then watch Longs and then those long
viewers would then translate into
becoming customers right so people watch
shorts and then they watch Longs and
they give you money right that was kind
of the prevailing thought but again when
we looked at the data it looked more
like this shorts viewers watch more
shorts and long viewers watch more Longs
and customers buy
more and so the point is that that these
are different audiences and I will make
a note here
that this can change my platform so I
might be a long viewer on one platform
and a short view or
another and where I do think the magic
happens is where you can have shorts in
one thing and so someone finds you on
Tik Tock but then they are a Longs
viewer on YouTube and then they watch
your Longs there so I do think there's
an element there but not the way the
narrative goes and so for us Longs drive
a lot more conversions than shorts
conversions being Book Sales opt-ins
applications all right and business
related content unsurprisingly brings
more business owners than not business
related content and so we are going to
double down on more Longs about that
stuff and change our short strategy to
keep the volume the same but focus more
on business
overall and again people watch
differently on different
platforms so making shorts in order for
people to on a different platform watch
long still carries as far as We Know
so despite the mega obsession with
shorts that has kind of prevailed for
the last few years because it was a new
you know format of content we're putting
now more emphasis on Longs overall for
now as far as we have
data so that's number
five now let's talk about the sixth one
that I'm going all in on assume more to
assume nothing all right so what does
this mean so let's start with assume
more and what that what that really
means broken down suum more means I made
content assuming people already knew
me
okay so here's an example the Alex rosi
guide to haters I might be like if I
don't know who Alex rosi is or I've
never seen that face before why do I
care if I see the day in the life of
Alex rosi yet again I assume everyone
knows me in this I'm I'm sharing these
mistakes with you as far as I'm
concerned for getting new people into my
world it wasn't made I assumed like
everybody's going to know me the Alex
rosi
everyone knows me no they're like who is
this guy right and here's why this
matters if you want your content to
bring people who don't know you which is
why many of you guys make content then
you can't assume they
do and so this is what this looks like
tactically from a headlines perspective
if I were to remake these today I might
try a first crack at business influencer
crushes haters and shows how you can too
okay so now if I'm clicking I would
understand at least that this guy is a
business influencer of some sort and he
crushes haters okay I might want to see
haters get crushed
uh day in the life of $200 million per
year CEO okay now the jet tells this me
that this Alex Heros from the the first
one before Alex Heros may be rich or
maybe he can afford a private jet but
now I know he's a CEO because I could be
a rapper I could be more realistically
when I walk around the place that I live
all the people that in my community
assume that I'm a football player it's
the number one thing I like so you uh
play football you on the hockey team and
uh I I say no I can nope nothing wrong
with that but no that's not what I do um
and then the third one there Alex rosi
Di 16 hour workday sixpack diet for
business owners whatever the point is is
that we actually make it welcoming to
everyone and so here's how we do this
tactically within the content itself so
we go from they know me to introducing
yourself every time so earlier I was
like I'm Alex rosi this is what I do
this is the the the subscribers I've
gotten whatever we introduce
ourselves two they know why they should
listen to me tell people why they should
listen to you every time
three the inside jokes you know how I
get no I don't know how you get please
fully explain the reference because that
references another piece of content that
I haven't seen because it's the first
video I've seen from you and if you tell
an inside joke and someone doesn't
understand the inside joke guess where
they are on the outside and guess where
people don't want to be on the outside
and guess where people spend money on
the
inside and number four going from acting
like you're already friends to
pretending everything goes to people who
have no idea who you are
and when you make content so people who
don't know you can enjoy it more
do and for those of you who are worried
because I can already hear the thoughts
that are coming up so let me just
address those right now I see
you I'm going to lose retention if I
introduce myself okay well let's play
the equal opposite would you rather
fewer people know who you are or more
people who have no
clue because on one hand we have some
people who know you and on the other
hand we have lots of people who also
don't know you so you're in the exact
same position you were
before two well aren't people going to
get sick of this you're going to keep
saying your name every time or keep
introducing yourself well from what I
can tell warm people like the reminders
and cold people need the
introduction and as a total side
note this is a fun little experiment for
everyone here you can run this when you
leave
here if who here actually who here
actually has posted content in the last
year okay good okay good for a second I
was like this would have been really bad
if no one had raised their hand
fantastic okay I want you to look at
last year and I want you to look at your
number one piece of content and this is
what I want you to do just post it again
and then let me know how it does and I
will bet you that it does just as well
or better than the stuff that you're
posting right now and let me tell you
one reason why I believe that to be true
because if you have been posting
consistently guess what's also happened
more people have entered your audience
and guess what they haven't seen that
amazing piece of content that everyone
from last year said was the number one
best thing you ever made and you know
what you said new people you don't get
that that was only for my old folks my
ogs they only get that no you got to
reintroduce some of the stuff your
greatest hits you got to bring that
stuff in so that the new people also
know what your greatest hits are so that
the lore continues to compound and
grow so number
three and this one or subo and this is
one for me personally I follow a bunch
of quote accounts I you know I I like
comedy and philosophy and like fighting
those like kind of categories that I
follow and gym equipment and so I get
quotes a lot on my Newsfeed but you know
what happens when I see a quote from
Sophocles or epicus yet again that
reminds me that I should just toughen up
and keep going I like the reminder I'm
not like epicus God you live 4,000 years
ago like Get over yourself no he's not
making new content but guess what people
still post it and people still read it
because we need to be reminded more than
we need to be taught at least I
do to give a little tactical one on this
for mainstream because this might
resonate for some of the older people in
the crowd there was this thing called
television a while back used to be big
anyways instead of having it on your
phone it was like this big screen on a
wall you a is a whole thing anyways I W
get into it it's like floppy disc
regardless floppy disc okay anyway so so
there used to be this thing where at the
beginning of every show there was a
theme s song right so they'd be like
cheers where everybody knows your name
and there's always a little introduction
it says produce by and all that stuff
and if those shows that spend gazillions
of dollars on testing chose to think
that despite selling more advertising
space it was worth having the same exact
theme song and introduction for the show
don't you think it might be worth that
for us too and here's an interesting
thing the last thing positive
associations and sticks if you actually
get sing song about how you introduce
yourself or the things that you relate
to you it starts to become something
that people expect and then they start
associating it with all the positive
other experiences they had with you so
if I always introduce something a
certain way and then I deliver value
afterwards they associate the
introduction with the value and guess
who else do they associate that with
you and so for those of you who are
concerned you can add variety to this
and I want to show you a cool little
real world example of this so the
Simpsons has the longest standing Show
to my knowledge that has existed on
television and the introduction is the
same now Bart would be like 70 by now or
whatever his actual age would be if it
was actual humans but it isn't right and
every introduction has barred at some
point in detention writing something on
the board for those of you who don't
know the Simpsons every one of the
introductions actually
changes every one of them and so they
still have the introduction that has all
the positive associations with the funny
times and the humor and the laughs that
you've had with the show but they
introduce a tiny bit of variety into
them to keep it interesting and then
what happens is people look forward to
these introductions because they want to
find the Easter egg the real fans now
get catered to and the new fans don't
know about it yet but they will and so
now you actually serve both sides of the
audience the people who know you and the
people who first who are just coming
cold
and so that's it small variation same
introduction you let the new people in
and you give something to the the people
who already know you so title it like
they don't know you introduce yourself
say why they should listen prioritize
the content that makes sense for
strangers deprioritizing the Vlogs the
hot takes the opinions
because if you can serve both audiences
serve both let the new people in rather
than have a wall they have to jump over
let them in on the joke fully explain
the references that you make make all
jokes inside jokes for
everyone and then finally mentally act
as though you're always talking to a
stranger because if the content does
well you
are at least that's what I'm going to be
doing and so that's the six big change
that we're doubling down on and so now
that we covered those changes in my
strategy I just want to get real for a
second everything has a cost and it's
not that other types of media or other
topics or other formats don't work
obviously we had a smorgus board we had
a huge variety of cornucopia Myriad
content types that we did over the last
40ish months and obviously we had 7.8
million subscribers and two billion
views during that time period in a niche
audience of business owners it's pretty
good and so it's not to say that other
things don't
work I'd even say that my mess ups also
work to a sort a small degree it's just
that they didn't work as well as
something else might have and so the
game at least as I see an entrepreneur
entrepreneurship is figuring out what's
my biggest bang for a buck right what's
the content that gets me the most of
everything because you only have limited
resources you have time money energy you
put it into your team and that goes onto
social media or the media that you that
you Market on and then that has output
and so if you can become more efficient
with the inputs you get you get more
output on the other side and so the
question becomes with the resources I
have how can I maximize the number of
the right people who find out about my
stuff
and so this is something that I live by
anything works better than nothing so
raise your hand right now if you haven't
made a piece of content in 90 days okay
just do something because if you do
something you will do better than what
you're currently
doing two some things work better than
others and three nothing works
forever and so the requirement of the
entrepreneur is to start doing something
see what works better and then do as
much of that as they possibly can for as
long as they can until it slows down and
then figure out what the next thing to
do is and then do as much as they can
with
that so is that helpful in terms of
understanding content in media yes
awesome do you feel like you got at
least one lesson without the scar saves
at least a tiny percentage of the $4
million that I spent learning what
didn't work so I can show you these six
things that do okay good would you like
more stuff like this
okay well then I've got a bunch of free
stuff that I can give you to help you
grow your brand and make some money that
be all right okay so if you're just
starting a business right now raise your
hand okay this is for you I'm the
co-founder of the school games inside
you'll find courses full day trainings
the easiest business model they know of
to use this med this Media stuff because
it's one thing to just say like oh great
I just watched this whole thing on media
now do I do well this gives you
somewhere to actually practice it like a
Sandbox you can learn it and you learn
by doing this is one of the lowest
Stakes way to make money get your first
dollar across the finish line and so fun
fact something I'm very proud of is that
right now 30 3.44% of people who finish
their first month make their first
dollar online by starting online
community I think that's pretty
cool and so you can start that for free
by going to school.com games all right
tell them I sent you so that's for
everybody raise your hand if you're
business uh uh you're starting a
business right now okay that's for you
now if you're a little further along in
your business Journey I've got free
stuff for you too all right trying to
feel like Santa Claus today I wrote
These two books right now which have
25,000 F store reviews they sold a
million plus copies and I make courses
for each of those books that are free on
my site you go to acis.com trining so if
you like this stuff you want to learn
about offers you about advertising more
about getting leads paid ads content all
of that stuff so you can start making
money within your business or scale it
from wherever you are to wherever you
want to go I've made this stuff for you
these are real courses it's not barred
anywhere you can click there watch them
all all right
see I put that for myself because this
is how I roll get in the get in the zone
so otherwise you guys are all amazing
you can go there for stuff that will
help you practice his stuff actually do
it in the real world because if you just
walk away from here today and you do not
execute anything you learned nothing and
so for the love of God just do one of
the things so you can get a tiny percent
of that $4 million and the 35,000 pieces
of content and the Thousand hours that I
spent recording just do one of them so
you can take that lesson for you thank
you guys
[Applause]